real threat other than this pawn but
keep in mind you're not even going to be
able to take our Bishop I'll have Roxy
for at the end of that variation so
maybe it's time just to play quiet move
King c7 and you just expect that the two
rooks and Bishop and to quote Maurice a
gaggle of pawns I like that a gaggle of
pawns is enough to win the day that
looks that looks simple that's just
that's just easy easy and by the way
there's no there's no counter play with
the F pawn either I've got that under
lock and key
although father House taking down and
seconds actually has to play rather
quickly
45 seconds here in the position and 1
minute and 15 seconds after he played
rotates f2 of course we're the increment
we can't overstate the time here but it
right that Eclat 30-second increment is
such a big one but it's go keep an eye
on yeah missus these particular moments
yes King to g3 right and I'm sure
there's a lot of choices but I do like
rooks III check once again I don't think
that's the only only move in the
position I think even maybe rook c4
actually has something to be said for it
as well I mean not completely a bad move
but
rooks III check seems obvious this is
the nightmare of Fabiano fans everywhere
is he it goes under 30 seconds oh by the
way they keep in mind that Fabiana can
can throw in a series of checks whenever
he wants and he could go like check
check right grab a couple of extra
minutes by just throwing in those extra
repetition like he's played and he's
doing that indeed he's taking your
advice yeah sir
well it's something that actually
I also learn from the Soviets they like
to make a repetition when they could
force it to just give you the impression
they have a draw anytime they liked it
so it's kind of a psychological make
sure you don't do it one time multiple
zeros for Caruana but that is not the
case obviously he has been gaining time
30 seconds a move every time he moves so
our clock times are not accurate yeah
we're waiting for this board to update
aha I see we're not getting updated on
the board but it does appear that rooks
III check was tossed in and we have I
think a couple of back and forth so that
Fabiano could gain a few minutes on his
clock and think about the best way of
reeling in victory and I think King c7
is the proper way to do it that's right
Fabiano now after gaining a little bit
of time in the clock seems to be
thinking yet again so we'll try to
adjust the situation here and you have a
how's it going over well the
world-champion is advanced this pawn as
we were we were looking at a rather
long-winded forcing line King h3 has
just been played
I thought a3 would be played per not the
only move by the way from Magnus Magnus
has another cagey idea which is to bring
the King over and put the rook here
don't quite get that so let's say a3
once again let's say rook over King and
this was the line that we were paying
attention to last time again like I
still let's stay with our our tournament
leader look at the webcam is we try to
reconstruct that position uh-huh we're
gonna take a look at the
the camera shot of Nakamura and Khurana
again almost caught myself they're
saying the right car here they are
Kimura is not looking pleased looking up
at the ceiling a massive crowd still
watching their name these guys are not
getting tired of it of course there's
bigger crowds over at les service right
and at the World Chess Hall of Fame but
you if you come to st. Louis you can
also watch the games in person so we see
actually that it looks like White's King
has gone to h5 whoa somehow how did that
happen no it's no no no Jay Forrester
okay so we see three check was played as
g4 has been played and then we did see
probably a series of choke you jack
right we're gonna do it one time just
for fun and then we'll go with King c7
thank you see seven did occur yeah we
see that came on c7 rate Baron now we're
up to date with the players and he
called me Fabiana was thinking they
would have a fun time by now and
actually we have updated the board now
and 37 seconds for Fabiano karamaneh
and a little over 17 minutes for
Nakamura so despite the winning
positioning that hobby I don't have so
we gotta keep our eyes on this just
because playing the increment is never
fun no strange things happen when you
cut the fall under time treble I play
blitz chest my whole life I've enjoyed
five-minute chess from the time I first
play chess and I played many many many
games where I've had seconds on my clock
and never felt nervous
however in classical chess when I have
minutes on my clock I suddenly do get
nervous Maurice your thoughts just a big
development in another game the other
game we are watching between Magnus or
Mike nice throw
Magnus Carlsen and I keep getting that
kids I'm just gonna call him Magnus from
that one a Magnus's game and Aronian x'
game this position we noticed the king
is going to march up if you try to get
this pawn to go down so Magnus said no
way I'm letting that happen and he
sacrificed upon here with the Move g5
allowing F takes G five and now rook to
be for saying no way I'm letting your
King go up the board so down up giving
back his extra pawn but not allowing the
White King to get active and the engine
say this is a reasonable idea and it's
not so easy to pick off this pawn your
King can't go up this epon might get
into trouble and this King is back to
the plan of bringing itself around so g5
a dynamic move clearly the world
champion is looking to win this game to
try to keep pace with his rival who
looks like he's going to run away from
the field magnets knows he needs to put
some points on the board a risky move g5
maybe not it looks like a good idea in
this endgame guys right because it
seemed very difficult for Magnus to win
otherwise I like this plan that LaVon
came up with and this counter idea what
a battle we're seeing here great move g5
I didn't have it on my Spidey radar but
that makes a lot of sense to keep
White's King passive and not allow it to
get to f6 where it can munch off a lot
of pawns right that was your key
defensive idea right and so now LaVon
needs to good night and needs a reset
mmmm'
not so easy at all suddenly okay yeah a
big challenge for LaVon what's he going
to do because he he invested a lot in
this idea of king h4 let me just show
you one example of something that is
probably a very bad idea for white is if
you go after this pawn with the rook
it's gonna take you so long that this
pawn the difference is that when your
rook isn't able to get behind a pawn in
time behind we get behind and that's all
she wrote party time
exactly so white doesn't have the white
doesn't have the time to go after this
pawn on h5 and he's got to come up with
something very clever indeed because
otherwise this Murray said King comes to
d7 worms its way around a c6 and maybe
it starts to pick off the e5 pawn also
another idea that's not out of question
either is a rook g4 rook takes g5 rook
takes Eve ePHI the idea - although you
don't want to get a three versus two but
the more I'm looking at this move g5 I'm
saying great plan and boy lavon's going
to have to be very very precise in terms
of holding this game if he can what do
you think do you think he's got it in
him today I don't know it's both players
Vaughn with a little bit more time but
shouldn't be too significant of a
difference seven and a half minutes
first five minutes right it is a bit of
a confusing position instinctively I
would think that black has more
resources than I'm finding so it means
that I'm just getting tired
this position is mean white has no black
power defense of resources than I'm
finding right now I'm not fine defensive
no black strike oh okay I'm sure White
has more defensive resources than I'm
finding because I'm not finding them and
I know that these rook endings are so
tricky and at the moment why it's not
even down a pawn but I'm having a hard
time coming up with a good plan so I've
got to make a pass so let me let me make
a pass for a moment let me just on my
board play the move rook a8 and try to
understand okay here at least I've got
this pawn at the g6 pawn is a source of
counter play but I'm seeing this move
rope g4 and I'm fearful that
the king could actually just come up
here and take this pawn but let's see
rook a seven King V five right that's
that one I like okay so now I'm
protecting this pawn and I've got a very
simple idea of going with the King this
King over here in the meanwhile has got
to get into the game the only way you
can do that is to play g6 toss that pawn
down and try to get your king up right
Jeff yes exactly
okay right so let's say I go down here
and what are we gonna try g7 sure okay
and away we go and this one looks
winning I'm still not sure I can toss in
a lot of checks and force your king in
front of the pawn and then go for g8
thinking h4 just like we were trying
before indeed well bit that actually I'm
wrong I know I am right with a pawn on
g7 of course you can't bridge your King
knows you're gonna have to stick it on a
- it's employee yeah or I'm thinking a 1
right ok so we got it here oh boy deep
breath here we go G 8 equals Queen is
this enough counter play for a meanie as
number one player geez geez geez geez so
now you're ready to try to get your work
to b2 or something huh right we have to
boy rope endings are tough so if a - so
I was thinking oops I'm sorry I was
thinking that rook comes down here right
we have idea of liberating the king with
rugby - so we keep going it's a long
winded variation I do apologize to the
audience here but this is what we do
and this looks like it should be a drunk
yeah yeah we're cool yeah Wow so on the
edge very nice idea by magnus carlsen to
give himself chances when a couple moves
in the Nakamura Chiron in the game and
Maryse has that for us well actually I
wanted to analyze another position this
game right here he did play queen da
Czech and rook back to c7 has been
played we can get to that in a second
but I wanted to show you guys a pretty
line in this position between Magnus and
LaVon rook c7 Czech is also playable
trying to drive the king away and in
this position King to f8 and now rook to
a7 getting behind the pawn and now rook
to e4 the other option of course is what
you talked about yeah is root 2 G 4 take
a look at this line g6 giving away the
pawn ok what's your idea and now g4
surprising move offering a second pawn
asking you to double your pawns well he
could take and that leads to a strange
position but what about this line rook
takes on g4 and suddenly rook to f7
check and you cannot get out of the
continuous checks because of course any
capture would lead to a stalemate so
some ideas hidden in the position we did
say that after g6 g4 here a takes g4 as
possible but now the king could get
active and look to try to get into the
position black would be best served
maybe playing the move g3 forcing him to
come backwards and take this pawn but
now it's very hard for black to get
anything going because of the rook on
the 7th rank this rook being tied down
if he takes this one then this one gets
captured in this pawn is not as powerful
as it ought to be so definitely some
weird chances in these rook and pawn
endings we know a lot of them lead to
draws but you still have to find the
moves guys yeah this time the resources
are so wonderful when you get to play
them when your opponent by it finds a
stalemate resource it's just horrible
like ah how could I let it go no I you
know it's great these these
means everybody always talks about how
important is the SteriPEN name but I
feel that sometimes you have to remember
work verse pawn that's really important
too because the Brooklyn Games will
often lead to work averse pawn a
position that's like accurately
calculate those end games do you have
enough counter play when you sacrifice
your rock absolutely absolutely
I had a dear friend Michael Frenette
unfortunately he has passed away he was
out of many times the champion of
Washington State and he said yes sir
study your end games I said why says
it's like cheating I said what it's like
cheating if you go in schooled and you
have an exam and your teacher says well
we're gonna ask this question about you
you're prepared you know the answer and
you're studying rook endings it's like
cheating because it's absolutely 100%
guaranteed if you're a tournament player
and you're an active player you're gonna
get rook endings so study your ex like a
mom telling their kid that vegetables
are bad for you vegetables are good for
you bad for you he's then the one who
eat them that sounds like the reverse
psychology was using mine you're like no
I it was a great encouragement in fact
they've worked big time I worked hard on
my endings speaking of endings in the
game between Kerry Juana and
hikaru here we see that Fabiano is just
finding a safe haven for his king
finally he's fled over to the Queen side
this is all she wrote folks I mean
everything is nice and consolidated at
this point and after rook c7 we can see
that no more big threats against the
king this Bishop on this pawn on f6f-5
pardon me is not going anywhere the f6
square is covered and I don't see
anything at all to be done I took on d5
it appears he did play Queen - yeah
equalizing a little bit
I'm not going down down to 6 minutes so
I'm surprised that Hikaru's continuing
to play beyond the fact that row rook g7
check could potentially end up
checkmating but now the white king I'm
just thinking a very simple Bishop c5
again you're covering always played
Fabiano
playing your move yeah but okay I mean
two rooks and a bishop versus a queen
and you're losing the a3 pawn and well
it's just it's just horrible I'm afraid
to say this it's not no reason to
continue play as I see it at least he's
twirling upon this bird the
international arbiter directing this 20
minute earlier said that he's pretty
impressed by macklemore's pawn throwing
skills okay like that's not a compliment
or an insult I don't know I always
thought it was an extremely bad habit I
mean we do have another move he had he
is not giving up yes okay he has played
Queen Queen b8 Maurice what do you think
yes you wanted to resign just because
the guys up some material come on just
complain about the resignation in the
other game we want to see the ending
we'll see the finish he I should play it
clearly is losing for black from our
eyes but the fans out there want to know
you know that King has been chased
around we just saw a crazy stale mating
line in another position so I I believe
in what Nakamura is doing he's making
moves until it's actually time to give
up and his Queen should just keep
harassing the King until Fabiano
approves it especially being in time
pressure
Fabiano has a minute and change on the
clock when he gets like three minutes
after he pumps up his his time by making
a lot of moves and maybe maybe five
minutes but until then I think the right
thing to do is to keep making moves even
though clearly it's busted for I agree
it is fun for us to watch how this game
will conclude and
I think more likely the game will
conclude when Nakamura uses his five
minutes and ends up just you know
himself or not if not gliding just kind
of fair fair enough I forgot about
Fabiana being slightly behind on time
but come on guys if you were to see this
move rook a to for a moment I mean you
just see that you're gonna lose this
pawn on a three your f pawns not going
anywhere I think there's an instinct
when there's a queen on the board even
if the the queen is totally outranked by
all these pieces to maybe play it a
little bit longer because there's always
these like little checks and potential
perpetual x' and i seven in that
position that did white did black excuse
me so so you know you talked about rook
a - yes now we don't expect him to do
that but you know the time pressure
strange things happen so I think he karo
with his bullet skills and speech monkey
around and to float and see what happens
next
guys have been known to make were
suppose than that yeah you've played off
six instead after o king b7 was played F
you know he's played accent f6 this has
been played yeah so f7 of course is
really well protected by bullfrog so
that's not a threat well I would again
I'm I'm eyeballing this this idea of
winning this pawn on a - I think I would
probably toss in a rook G to check just
to see where that King might end up or
maybe even simply rook c7 upon me Roxy -
with the idea of just snap the pawn on a
300 okay I am tired Bishop takes 83 I
love grabbing pawns I would grab this
pawn as well right so no way to take
advantage of that losses Bishop only one
check only one reasonable check on the
board and
check on d5 King well actually I have a
choice here King b6 as well as King
Locker
our second check on t4 with Bishop c5
very precisely that's that's total
consolidation that's over
so Bishop takes a three obvious I'm
still playing basically on the increment
about one minute for Fabiano and about a
little less than five by the way since
I've never had to ask is there a second
pardon me is there a time control after
so he's going to be playing on increment
for the rest of the game in fact both
players will be okay thank you for that
clarification I wasn't certain I should
know these things
maybe I should just read the program
guide Maurice rotary thoughts the other
game did feature a sacrifice that we had
anticipated the move g6 was played after
rook check King over this rook was on g4
in this moment why play g6 clearing the
seventh rank of pawns so that now the
black King is frozen on the back rank
and the King back to g2 g5 and King to
f3
this position is looking more and more
drawn White's King now released blacks
King stood on the back row an extra pawn
for black but it doesn't seem as though
he's gonna be able to make good use of
this so it seems as though Aronian will
be able to pull off a draw here in which
case there'll be one person only one
person in the tournament sitting on 50%
that would be to pallav can you imagine
that after he started off - - he'll be
sitting on 50% while everyone else in
the tournament would be a minus one
except for Nakamura who will go 2-2
after this loss and Fabiano two and a
half points ahead of two Paulo three
points ahead of everybody else just
dominating the tournament looking quite
relaxed it it will look as though this
tournament is over if he does do what
he's supposed to do right now and win
the game guys Wow so we got a couple
more moves in Kara Rana Nakamura and my
prediction is that Nakamura will resign
soon he just looks he looked angry after
that
the last move being Queen d5 to d8 right
okay so we had this position we saw the
move Queen d5 check anticipated that
after King b6 we get to meet Queen d4
check no no no no you're not picking up
the rook I get to play Bishop c5 Queen
d8 was played by Hikaru Fabiana having
to play a little bit quick quickly as
he's on increment and he played Bishop
c5 c5 and now uh looks like he has made
another Queen move it looks like Queen
BHO he really only has a queen so I
guess that's not too astonishing of a
prediction is it I'm sorry what did he
play jacketed hollow by route to b7 to
b7 so there now he looks like he's
looking directly in the camera as if he
can hear it
oh boy I want to disturb his
concentration no first down baby just
for that moment it felt like a wall was
being broken down well king a7 and now
we're really in a kind of a fortress
cave the rook is nicely behind the F
pawn nothing did the bishop could even
go back to b6 and then one day guess
what this a pawn is going to just go up
the board Oh No the rook is now behind
the ball yeah yeah magically and he's
gonna push the beep on and he's gonna be
all she wrote when that pawn goes down
the board I think it's a very good time
now to start looking at the boy and
thinking yeah this is over when you can
close your eyes and make the move sure
but III for those at home were watching
I really think that if you have a queen
no matter how many pieces your opponent
has you shouldn't resign because you
never know when you get some kind of
Perpetual I mean of course these are
super rad masters but it's I think it's
really important especially when your
opponent isn't I'm pressure
don't resign too early yeah usually you
always have an opportunity to resign
that is a good point later he said
resignation earlier unless you get
checkmated going back to our other game
magnus carlsen world champion magnus
carlsen
you will die later yeah okay so when we
have left it maurice was mentioning that
with this rook nicely placed on the
seventh rank cutting off blacks King
Black has a lot of trouble making
progress but he has tried King g6 and h4
trying to create a little bit of a
weakness on g3 so that maybe he could go
back here with rook g4 and be able to
take this pawn with check well I think I
would just take this guy frankly take on
h4 and in case of rook takes h4 just
wait King III uh well there's a little
trick in the position I beg your pardon
there is a little nasty
okay so Magnus does have some some
little tricks here and the well go the
other way every way I I thought that the
thing I wanted to avoid is I didn't want
to really allow let me let me play a
move for black another what's wrong with
my screen okay I'm getting a little
trouble oops
as h g3 been played already h g3 has
been played already right so the thing
that I was I didn't want to allow black
was the opportunity for her black to
play h3 and maybe the h2 pawn you know
get in h3 and g4 so King c3 but h g3 has
been played
we anticipate recaptures sorry I should
point out that King takes would be a
horrible mistake
thanks to g2 so we don't take the rook
we take the pawn
and we come back here with the rook now
okay
so now how should we defend this chair
maybe knew that King away to be two for
instance okay King to be two so that we
think g3 doesn't go much a true and then
I think that what Magnus has to do is
move his King back over to the Queen
side hold on rookie 4 as well I think so
so weight can be - you want to play
rookie for now yeah King bee - rookie
for I apologize much stronger yeah and
so sorry King III yes one well you want
to go after this pawn after all well I
don't know about Keaney okay well you're
not really afraid of rough check right
because then I'll get King T over 55 you
take with the Kings I don't get both of
the pawns right
yeah I think so so king a3 I was
thinking the king of Han ending
no no chances for black in the king of
parting gate g4 takes takes game two
tonight
Magnus just has played the movie three
in the game I beg your pardon with
Magnus play the move a three in the game
we're here no no H takes g3 so the King
stole indeed yeah and then rook g4 um
yeah they can't get caught up let's see
two second sorry folks I just have to
refresh my monitor so after after h6h
takes rook g4 king d3 a3 I see you're
utilizing that same school or IDs over
k3 you were 63 right and so after that
LaVon is started shuttling his King over
to e3 and now after Luke takes g3 check
King to d4 whoa so trying to get the d6
square now I'm really confused I think
that Magnus is winning yeah I would just
play rook and we have a handshake in the
other game so Fabiano Carolina winning
his fifth game of the tournament
that's know what your favorite hobby I
know nickname is mr. perfect
Don Fabiano come up with a brand new one
because we're gonna need to pick the
right one is uh finally I know just
slashes through this tournament
superlatives of piling up I had system
it's a historic tournament the strongest
tournament of all times I was expecting
a big big big fight for first place and
one guy is just running away with this
event I'm having to catch my breath
like I can't I can't believe I mean yeah
sure one misstep today a new theme be
sure to age four
otherwise just phenomenal and absolutely
words I'm lost
we have one game left and it seems that
LaVon has miss stepped I'm trying to
learn yeah trying to get his King active
in the d6 I think we're good on g5 it's
also running away well exactly I think
we're gonna see three wins three
decisive games I beg your said okay just
black to black wins in one white win
yeah exactly and king c5 was the last
last move but hold on do I have this
right yeah you've got the right position
on the board King so king c5 just played
just just played but and now Magnus play
rook to e3 exactly and he's got two
connected past part two outside pass
pawns and by the way one of those big
ideas was for a right to get the King to
d6 in a variation like ring x87 in king
b6 Magnus just disallowing that cut him
off with rook d3 there's no king she's
not gonna be wrong here
no it's resigns it's just too one of the
part one of the passed pawns makes a
queen and it's just resigns it's a it's
a stunning turn of events for example
King c4 is one example of how these
passed pawns promote themselves to a
queen very pretty you can stop one but
you can't stop to Maurice what do you
think about this crazy round which ends
up being just as exciting and some of
our others completely shocking you're
watching the top players Wow the game is
over
just falling apart now Aronian remember
how close he was
can we talk about we talk about Khurrana
closing in on Carlsen what about the way
he's distancing himself from Aronian I
mean they're separated now by about 30
rating points when he was actually be
high in Aronian to start this tournament
an incredible secret I mean have you
ever seen anything like this at the
highest levels this is just incredible
not just
Fabiano's run away play so far but just
the way other players are playing
including the way Aronian has handled
himself here just a complete collapse
for him unfortunate the moment where he
erred well right here after the move
rook to g4 he should have instead played
King to d2 right now stepping out of the
check we still see this on camera we see
them chatting but if we get a chance to
analyze this position just a bit to see
the critical moment when he erred and
you can see him there just looking
pretty disgusted at the moment not not
at all happy with his play just getting
up walking away from the board Carlson
of course winning feeling much better
about himself for sure just winning an
endgame that was basically gifted to him
now they're just walking away from the
table and so we get a chance right here
in this moment after rook to g4 the key
move he should have played of course was
was sorry right in this moment he should
have played King to d2 like that's
that's the magic move right now move
your King back toward this pawn here and
if takes on g3 then just take on a4 and
his King steps out of the checks he
allowed this position to change
otherwise in Magnus the Magnificent
winning in end games his persistency
showing itself and now he is at 50% so
he is joined to Paul off both of them
and 50% before the rest day still two
and a half full points behind Keira
wanna that's gonna be a tall order to
chase down that guy he's putting on a
pace like we haven't seen in many a year
five and OH to start the tournament I'm
sure everybody's happy that they have a
rest day right now except maybe this guy
named Fabiano he's like let's keep
playing
oh stop now magic is coming out of my
fingertips what an exhilarating start to
our tournament by this young player the
youngest player in the competition guys
oh that's right Fabiano you caught
Magnus magnificent and Fabiano fabulous
so we are going to kill you with our
it's going to be terrible is gonna get
worse as people die by checkmater my
loss you will die by pond it's gonna be
worse and a shocking loss by LaVon he's
normally an a superb rook rook ending
player in something is not clicking for
LaVon he hasn't looked good at all even
though he's even won a nice game against
Opel off at the end he had a bad
position and a bad opening that got him
there so lavon's not looking very good
and now an even score and also at least
means not narrowing the gap further
between him and Khurana
for the world rankings we do have our
tournament leader perfect five Oh going
into the rest day
Fabiano Cara Juana well Hawaii five-o
right this guy is taking everybody down
with his play Fabiano welcome to the
show
have you ever can you ever have imagined
starting five and OH against this gang I
mean this are some serious players and
you've just blitz the field in the first
half
no I couldn't have even dreamed that I
would start with a perfect score but
okay all the games are going perfectly
for me I don't know if it's it's a
matter of luck or I'm just playing well
I think I am playing well but yeah there
has been some luck in volt but in any
case it's a fantastic start I couldn't
have imagined that I would do something
like this we see you had a strong game
here and this position g4 and then you
had the chance to play the most bishop
age four and just nailed the position
you pointed out that you missed this
when you when you saw him get between
back and start to create some perpetual
check chances how did you feel did you
feel like something was wrong it sure to
work that hard to win the game yeah I
felt like it was pretty much winning
before and I had complicated it quite a
lot I missed his manoeuvre Queen e2
Queen d3 for some reason I stopped to in
my preliminary calculations I stopped
after king of seven and then I realized
that he is queen is
starting to cause some problems I
completely missed Bishop h4 that would
have been a nice way to end the game but
I didn't see it week we can forgive you
for missing one or two moves in this
tournament the way you have been playing
then you were able to get a stranglehold
later were you happy when you saw him
play f5 instead of King f1 like now
things that settle down you just take on
d4 I couldn't can't say I was happy I I
had about two minutes and it was very
difficult to calculate everything
there's a lot of checks I was worried
that I'd blunder my bishop and lose but
yeah after f5 I didn't see anything for
him it seemed like I was winning yeah
King f1 was a better chance I felt like
I was winning but it's very complicated
what's the secret what's going what have
you done differently for this tournament
that's making you play so well I wish I
knew I don't know I'm just I'm just
playing a the way I normally do but
somehow it's going just going better
I think I'm playing a bit more
confidently bit faster trying to take
less time in the middle game here it was
very complicated but I I think I made
some decent moves at a good pace and
that helped me gain an advantage later
on I made a comment that the other
players are happy to see a rest day are
you happy to see a rest day
are you very happy why is that you're
playing so well yeah my result is great
but I'm still tired the result might not
show it but all the games have been
difficult and and it's good to take a
break question are you interested in
tena no I don't think that will happen
but I'm interested in winning as many
games as I can what about the situation
in the tournament you're two and a half
points that's unheard of
against Magnus Carlsen is two and a half
points behind you
Levon Aronian is three maybe four points
behind you know how is can you can you
imagine well three three and a half
points but how could you imagine this
kind of result it just seems really epic
just even out of context of yourself
just any player doing this well if
Magnus was
we wouldn't be so surprised I guess but
for me it's pretty unusual but okay I
mean I can't complain you know and yeah
okay I just have to say that the
tournament still isn't over that
anything can happen and I have to keep
on playing well I really don't want to
screw it up last question what's your
favorite nickname is it fabulous far
beyond Oh mr. perfect
what's the other one Jen helped me out
they've been throwing a lot of Aviano
down Fabiana so we stopped one of those
people who know me just call me Fabi
that's that's about it I don't really
don't really like any nicknames Fabi all
right well the man with one name now so
we we really appreciate your play and
best of luck in the rest of your games
Fabi like something Bad's gonna happen
but the way he's playing he can be
called anything he wants back to you
guys well at least when he's in the room
when he's when he's gone we'll use some
of them more superlatives Bobby and his
tweet about how impressed he was by
Fabiano very nice as I like it like it
it's soft its endearing very good Don no
no we're gonna stay away from Don coming
and as we go into the rest day just a
reminder we are going to be here
tomorrow so don't tune in or tune in and
wait for 24 hours and let's take a quick
look at the standings as we go into the
rest day of course this one's not hard
to guess Fabiano Keira wanna with a
perfect 500 score huh man behind him not
just behind him but way behind him
Veselin Topalov and magnus carlsen booth
with two and a half out of five even
scores max team last year to grab 2 out
of 5 and the Kuro Nakamura and Levon
Aronian
both tied for last with one and a half
points now we do have one player on the
upswing and world champion magnets curls
and he's getting set up for an interview
about his victory today against Levon
Aronian exactly I'm sure he'll be very
pleased with the result and just rather
stunned like the rest of us watching
Fabiana win and here he is world
champion magnus carlsen is with Maurice
Ashley thanks Jen with world number 1
magnus carlsen after a victory today
welcome to the show Magnus this game was
tough I mean there were real chances to
just be a draw but you seem to be able
to pull it off what happened that gave
you those opportunities well I think it
was pretty equal in the middle game
perhaps it was a little bit better then
it sort of turned around I think when I
got in this b5 BC 4 and then I I hope
that I might have some some chances in
in the long game but well then he
sacrificed the pawn which was probably a
decent idea we we eventually got this to
this rook end game which should be
should be drawn but it's not so easy so
it was there a clear draw to you was at
the moment when he may be allowed you to
get that gh4
takes on g3 and then maybe he could have
equalized there yeah well he could have
traded my past a pawn for his G and you
fonts with with a probable draw but not
not an easy draw at least and he decided
to yeah when he allowed the HTG 3 of
course it was it was lost but I think at
that point it was very very difficult
anyway it's not every day that numbers
one and two in the world play each other
and that's not the key game of the day
you managed to win of course always a
great thing to beat a rival like LaVon
but everybody's watching that watching
Fabiano and thinking what is happening
here this guy is five and oh and he
played another great game today as a
star player yourself who was played
great tournaments what's your thought on
on his play so far well I I guess
his his game today was probably his
least convincing so far but nevertheless
what can I do I mean winning five games
in such an event is something that
rarely happens and obviously with
winning five games in behind a row of
that it's something that has barely
happened before so it's it's amazing but
for me I'm just happy to to get going
myself and and yeah to to be able to to
start my own tournament maybe eventually
see if I can do something but what are
your thoughts you're at two and a half
he's at five it is only the first half
of the event with five rounds to go is
this tournament over no but it's I mean
obviously it's not enough for me to beat
him with black and that says quite a bit
that that meetings later with blackest
it's not even going to be close to
enough so only but I'll just focus on my
own game on games I mean today was was
good today was I think more or less at a
normal level the kind of chess I want to
play and if I can continue with that I
can at least have a good tournament but
obviously first place is it's way out
there
the rest day feeling good for a rest day
or not you want you'd like to keep going
no it's okay
it's always good to keep going after a
rest day but no I mean after after when
especially since Chicago had a tough
loss today but I mean it's it's a tough
event and I'm probably gonna be happy
about that rest day at the end well
thanks so much for joining us and get
your rest and we look forward to your
game in two days
thank you world champion Magnus Carlsen
pulling off a victory in his style
grinding his opponent down and he's at
50%
going into the rest day guys Thank You
Maurice although you might have to win a
game with burning candles before oh yes
well for the rest day we do have the
burning candles not the most thrilling
round that one of the most decisive
rounds no I thought the results were
great I just did some of the other games
where we're really exposed it was a day
of strategy well like in for example the
game that Magnus mom wasn't the
thrilling game I mean we stand back and
we applaud all the nice plotting moves
that increase the advantage but it was
just a game it was just a tough tough
round to study any games and you were
telling a story about how I shouldn't
cut up on Fridays hanging a manual for
all the grandmasters society including
Magnus and Magnus hey did you read it
yeah you could say yes he has gotten a
couple of you have learned recently
that's true always always possible to
reread it right and we have a final
thought from grandmaster Maurice Ashley
as we head to the rest day no question
about it this games these games today
were not as thrilling as previous days
but chess is a fight first emmanuel
astor said just as a struggle and it's
he who can struggle
the hardest or she who can fight the
most and endure the most that wins those
games and that's what we saw today
tenacity on the players determination
with the rest day coming they decided to
give it all and it was possible for the
world champion to win his game a former
world champion Veselin Topalov to win
his game but let's be serious there's
only one guy's name that seems to count
in this tournament and everyone sitting
in amazement Fabiano Khurana winning a
game after a slip at one moment but
still having the tenacity having the
determination of course his opponent had
to make some inferior moves as well but
he went ahead and he's now at five and
oh I mean everybody sit back and think
about that five and Oh in the strongest
chess tournament ever that is huge I am
amazed and mystified and I'm looking
forward to the rest day but I can't wait
to get back and watch what this is gonna
finish like as the other players gun for
him to try to pull him back to earth
it's gonna be a thrilling finish guys
Thank You Maurice it's been a pleasure
commenting in the first half of this
tournament with Maurice and Yasser and
having Karin's reports outside so don't
miss the second half we will see you
guys on Tuesday at 2:00
and 150 Central Standard Time here in
the Central West End come live in pea to
visit